[Music]
Hello, today is December 17, I greet you,
Andrés González, and these are the
most relevant news of the day. The
recount of votes continues in the race
for district commissioner C. The
Republican candidate, Antoni Sarollo,
requested the recount of votes after
losing the race.  Against Democrat
Rush Miller by just 10 votes to win
Anthony would be the only Republican in the
House of Commissioners Clark County
certified the results of the
lesson last week but
election officials say they identified at
least 140 anomalies in this race the
recount of  votes will take 5 days
the plan for the distribution of the
vaccine has been detailed by
health sector officials the 112-
page document includes the process to
determine who will be vaccinated first
these people have been divided into
three tiers and will start the
administration process at the  month of December
the first to receive the vaccine will be primary care
workers  first aid and the
health sector as well as
vulnerable people the second tier will start
as soon as January and include
people at high risk the third tier
of people includes all
residents of the state of nevada and they
will be able to start receiving the vaccine
during  the spring
the search continues this morning for two
climbers who were hiking
the mountain they are mounted on the program according to
the night county official the two
people were walking on a trail that
collapsed behind them
rescue teams are still looking for the work today Monday
art called seven magic
mountain will be giving it a
beautifying retouching all this week so if you
plan to visit that place you will have to
choose very well where you are going to take your
photos for instagram
we will see the extended forecast
today we have a day with winds and  a
maximum of 69 degrees with a minimum of 46
so we will stay for the rest of the
week wishes you an excellent  One day
Andrés González informed you and this was his
brief informative the news now in
Spanish
[Music]